à voisins le bretonneux le centre de
placement de la protection judiciaire va
réouvrir après une fermeture en 2012 il
devrait accueillir six jeunes entre 16
et 18 ans ayant commis des délits
objectif permettre leur réinsertion une
décision reçue avec une certaine réserve
par les riverains de ce côté là on est
très très très inquiet quoi sur le
devenir de la tranquillité du quartier
je ne suis ni pour ni contre je suis
plutôt inquiète
opposé à cette réouverture le conseiller
municipal olivier alfonso dénonce le
manque de transparence du maire je ne
connais pas la condamnation de ces
jeunes qui vont intégrer la maison qui
est derrière moi
donc si elle a les informations je les
invite à aller rendre public lors du
conseil municipal ou informé les élus
que nous sommes
habitant le quartier olivier tyrol a
rédigé une pétition contre cette
décision
53 personnes ont déjà signé le document
pourquoi on n'y a pas contacté les gens
disent on attendait on va se réunir on
va vous expliquer les choses qui est ce
qui se passe non là c'est on nous met
devant le fait accompli et vous n'avez
qu'un droit c'est de vous taire le maire
alexandra rosetti affirme avoir
communiqué dès qu'elle a eu connaissance
du projet elle a organisé une réunion
publique avec les principaux riverains
et elle se veut rassurante en prenant le
dossier en main avec la création d'un
comité de suivi spécifiques
j'ai eu le sentiment quand même que les
directeurs que nous avions en face de
nous était vraiment décidé à tout faire
pour que les choses se passent bien que
ce soit très cadré voilà les jeunes ne
sont pas sûrs voisins en journée ils
vont dans d'autres centres ils sont
occupés ils réapprennent l'autonomie on
aura des réunions régulières pour voir
comment les choses se déroulent les
travaux sont en train d'être finalisé la
résidence devrait ouvrir à partir du 1er
octobre